my family that's what makes me feel
we're really excited to talk to you
today
um we know that Blue Beetle is filmed
for IMAX so I was wondering could you
tell us a little bit about when you made
the decision to film the movie for IMAX
yeah
um I think right off the bat we wanted
to have the opportunity to bring to IMAX
the best immersive experience that we
could do for this particular movie
specifically because we know how great
this type of movies look on IMAX but we
have yet to see our culture in IMAX so I
wanted to see ourselves represented in
the biggest screen possible so right off
the bat when I started working with
Pavel we knew that we wanted to shoot
for IMAX when did in the process did you
start to think about which scenes you
wanted to use the IMAX expanded aspect
ratio in yeah we went through that
process with editorial just looking what
are the best scenes that could do the
IMAX pop-up that that we're not just
um action sequences we also wanted a
little bit of the other places that show
like Puerto Rico and how it looks and be
able to have moments of just family
intimacy and family Dynamics also Sean
shown in that immersive format I know
you mentioned that you wanted to focus
on more than just the action and like
also the family side of things but are
there any particular scenes in like in
your mind that are your favorites that
you were able to like you know shoot
with that extra picture for fans yeah
like for me there were like I I like
that there's like this um Mariscos Place
dinner that is not an action sequence
but it's just such a beautiful
day that we had that day in this
beautiful location in Puerto Rico called
pinones that it benefited a lot from
getting that extra frames uh on the
bottom and the top and also a lot of the
Warners that we have in the movie we
wanted to have that whole immersive
experience feel the whole room
um and I think like the the most
exciting part for me that Place nicely
because it's the way we did it worked
out very well
was on the transformation sequence
that were inside the house like you know
this uh humble Latino house and
everything looks normal but once the
Scarab jumps in his face it pops into it
so you're like right sucked into it and
I it looked really really awesome yeah I
think I saw an interview piece and the
cast was saying you told them to just go
crazy
like they did and everyone was on fire
during that scene and
just loving it it was really great yeah
I wanted them to be like I I described
what was happening and I said like just
react like you would even if you feel
slapstick yeah I'm like why not just go
for it like let's have fun and let's
make this scene that could be otherwise
very horrific
if it wasn't for the levity and the
humor that the family brings to it yeah
and you definitely found like so much
levity and humor in the film along with
the emotional moments too when the
action it has everything yeah yeah he
has everything for everyone
um and then speaking of that like why do
you want fans to go and experience the
movie in IMAX
um honestly because when I first saw it
in IMAX I was so blown away by the how
it almost covers my peripherals you know
like you like you were looking at the
movie like this as opposed to just here
so being able to to look at everything
that's happening on the frame I think
unconsciously gives you that sense of
immersion
and by being immersed I feel like you
automatically feel like you're part of
the action or you're part of the story
and in this case you're part of the
family you're in it with them and also
the sound is amazing uh I remember I was
doing QC over in Puerto Rico when they
were doing the QC in Playa Vista and
they sent me videos of the of the
parking lot trembling with the sound of
our movie so for me that was kind of
like what I wanted to do it's like I
don't it doesn't need to be loud you
just need to feel it and the same thing
I feel goes on with the visuals like in
order to get that fully immersive
experience I think the arm IMAX frame is
the one to go
um this reminds me of a question I have
coming up but it was about
um I read in Wikipedia that used to be
in a punk rock band yeah and I was
curious like did your passion for music
influence how you approach the sound for
the movie and 100 and and with IMAX 2
like you can like make your own bespoke
like audio track like can you tell us a
little bit about like how your like
musical influences like inspired the way
that you wanted the movie to come across
with the sound definitely uh I wanted a
lot of our soundtrack to feel like it
would be a playlist that exists in every
household so if the idea was to I made a
playlist that included all the songs
that each family member would listen to
and by doing so I was able to tap into
Nostalgia like music that I grew up uh
also the writer pitch in music that his
family grew up with and by doing so
we're able to bring this amazing
um
plethora of of sounds that go from you
know Regional music or more traditional
music to reggaeton to Cumbia
salsa Rock Punk uh we even have Cypress
Hill and monthly crew in it because you
know we we take we also consume pop
culture so
um and we also have a lot of great bands
that might be unknown in the U.S that
resonate with everybody Latin America I
think all those noises that go from like
garage Rock to like some deep bass rap
or something I think they all influence
a lot of the sounds that we're trying to
do so we wanted to give it that
nostalgic
vibe to it and I think the sound helped
a lot yeah and I you mentioned like pop
culture references and I felt like there
were a lot of references in the movie
that I filmed like the fans were picking
up on and I think especially with DC
movies and superhero movies fans love to
pick up on like little Easter eggs and
things like that and the cool thing when
you have like the extra pitcher there's
more things to notice correct correct
like in the bug layer for example
there's a lot of Easter eggs uh uh all
over the place and being able to open it
more you could like I remember when we
were editing we were edited kind of like
with the bars but when we open it like
oh my gosh I forgot all those stuff was
there so definitely people are gonna see
not just the Easter eggs but also the
amazing work that the that the
production designer and his team was
able to do and next I have a question
for you which is our favorite question
to ask our filmmakers
um and we're opening it up so if there's
any movie that you could experience for
the first time or again in IMAX what
movie is that for you
oh wow
what movie could I
Indiana Jones uh oh I'm the Last Crusade
because that was the first movie I
remember watching in the movie theater
and that was the movie that kind of like
ignited my curiosity and passion for
Cinema
and given that it was such a
transcendental experience for me as a
kid
I would love to see that in IMAX it's
funny you would say that because there
are moments when I was because I thought
of Indiana Jones on the ride and there
were moments when I was watching Blue
Beetle and I felt like I was on a ride
and I was like Blue Beetle needs its own
amusement park oh I hope so that would
be so good okay and so um but yeah
there's definitely moments where I felt
that in the film yeah we definitely
played uh the same way that there's
Easter eggs for fans of DC uh and comic
books there's also a lot of Easter eggs
and homages to the films that made us
including Indiana Jones okay and um I
saw you speak at a fan screening I think
it was in London and you spoke about
um how the theme of this movie is family
like helping you fulfill your destiny I
was wondering can you speak a little bit
about how your family influenced your
personal journey into filmmaking oh I
mean into filmmaking was a little bit
hard because of course what the family
my family once was best for you yeah and
my family might at first not understand
that there is a future to be had uh not
only making movies but actually
following your dreams or pursuing art
for that matter
um my family comes from very poor so
being able to provide a location for us
and protect us and give us everything
they couldn't have was their main goal
so I always I always understood why they
um they will protect me from any sort of
uh
different outcome that could have
happened in my life but at the end of
the day when they saw that they
couldn't talk any sense to me I feel
that at the end of the day they they
ended up supporting because they were
like if we don't support him
he's gonna do it on his own and at the
end of the day without them I wouldn't
be able to be where I am today
because I don't take any of those
sacrifices lightly and that's what we
aim to do with this movie uh besides
telling the story of Harry man Blue
Beetle and introducing this amazing
character to the world as the new
superhero of of the first superhero of
the new DCU I wanted to make this a love
letter to
to our family and the people that came
before us that sacrificed a lot for us
to be where we are to have the life that
we have and they are heroes in their own
right so I wanted to give them that
chance to shine yeah and you know
earlier you mentioned you wanted to film
the movie for IMAX because you hadn't
seen a story like that in IMAX before
but now people will and like they'll
feel like hey I can do it and like feel
inspired as well that being able to
inspire
um
you know future generations to to feel
empowered to not only tell their own
stories but also follow their dreams
because it is not an easy Journey
but nothing worth having in life is
gonna be easy and the fact that I could
from even from the lack of resources
that I had I was able to be where I am
today and inspire people for me that's
kind of like
the biggest thing I feel I could do
more than making a movie is if somebody
from a neighborhood like mine
shoe says to not stay on the streets and
pursue the Arts for me that's actually a
win I wanted to ask you like what led
you to Casting sholo marijuana in the
role and like what are you excited for
fans to see from his performance
um
so I when I met cholo I met cholo like a
couple years ago at Sundance and I think
he had done just one season of Cobra Kai
and but he was introduced to me as you
know this upcoming actor but
because I never saw him perform I was
really Blown Away by his Persona by who
he was outside of the camera
um he was very Charming super smart uh
well-versed but at the same time very
much his age and the love that he had
for his family he's always with his
family and he also has martial arts
background so when when I get the
opportunity to track this movie and they
asked me who did I want to cast for the
role of Jaime Reyes it was a no-brainer
that I wanted somebody like sholo
because not only does he look like a
copy paste of Jaime Reyes in the comic
he also embodies in his own life the
characteristic that makes high muscle
special
so all of that combined just made it
really easy so at the end of the day
when people see sholo being Jaime
for me it was really hard to see them
apart because the way he relates with
his family in the movie is the same way
Shawna relates with his family in real
life so I think they're gonna get a very
honest and authentic
kid who is trying to find his place in
the world and who ends up being the hero
when nobody else was willing to step up
for his family and for me having that
Journey will he doesn't shy away from
his family or from who he is but again
he Embraces it and he lets them be part
of that formation for me that is what I
hope people think away from it